الينا من عمان خليل العسكري والاستراتيجي
لواء فايز الدويري اهلا بك سيد اللواء كيف
يمكن فهم هذا الجدل الدائر بخصوص سوليدار
روسيا تقول انها ان قوات فاجنر بالفعل
سيطرت عليها اوكرانيا في ذلك انت كيف ترى
هذه التطورات
الفجوه بين التصريحات ضيقه حتى عدم
الاعتراف الاوكراني لا ينفي التقدم
والوصول الى مركز المدينه لكن الاختلاف
حول مفهوم السيطره مفهوم السيطره هو يعني
همم فرض الواقع كامل القضاء على المقاومه
وان كانت بجماعات صغيره
وتمشيط المنطقطقه اذا الحديث يدور حول
مفهوم كلمه السيطره فيما الجانب
الاوكرانيه يعتبر ان وجود جماعات
تقاتل وان كانت متباعده لا يزال يعني ان
هناك نقاب تحت سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
اعتقد ان السلدار موضوعها ان لم يكن حسن
فهو وقد شارف على الحسن بصوره كامله
والسيطره عليها النهائيه ستكون خلال وقت
وجيز جدا همم استنادا حتى الى التصريحات
الاوكرانيه وليس الى قائد جماعات ثانيه
طبعا بدار مفتاح الجبهه هذه جبهه الدمباس
كما يقول ال- همم كل الخبراء لانها تتحكم
في همم تحكم السيطره على باخموت همم لديها
همم انفاق يعني تتسع للرجال وعتاد ودبابات
لكن ايضا ما نريد ان نفهمه لماذا فجر في
هذه الجبهه المهمه بالتحديد
لماذا فاجنر لان القوات الروسيه تعثرت في
عملياتها العسكريه في منطقه باخمت لفتره
طويله وبالتالي الاستخدام الاولي لقوات
بادنر لانها اكثر خبره واكثر مهارات ويبدو
اكثر ان صياعا للاوامر الصادره من
قياداتها وبالتالي تعتبر قوات محترفه
لديها خبره تراكميه في سوريا في مالي همم
في همم في ليبيا في افريقيا الوسطى
فبالتالي هي جماعاته بالعصر هم اما جماعات
همم او افراد تقاعد ومن الخدمه العسكريه
تحديدا من القوات الخاصه او جماعات لديهم
الرغبه والهوايه في ممارسه هذه النوع
والجميع يعتبر هذا الامور قوات مرتزقه لكن
يستخدم هذا المصطلح اذا قاتلت خارج حدود
البلد اذا هم اعلى مهاره وكفاءه
وتدريبا واكثر على خوض المعركه لهذا السبب
تم الزد بهم اولا على معركه على جبهه
باخمت ثم تم الانتقال عندما استعصت باخ مت
علاء فاجنر وعلى الجيش الروسي والقوات
الخاصه الروسيه تم الاتجاه الى سوليدر لكن
في عجاله سوليدار انتم تحدثت والتقرير
تحدث دعني اقول سوليدار يجب ان يطرح
السؤال ماذا بعد ماذا بعد سوليدار لان
السوليدار تعتبر الخاص للرخوه لباخ موت
لشبكه المواصلات
لكرامتوس سلافيا مسك السيطره عليها اذا ما
تمت حقيقه ستطرح سؤال اضافي اين ذات ستذهب
القوات الاخرانيه المقاتله وتقدر بالالاف
هل ستذهب لتعزيز جبهه
وتتخلى عن طرق المواصلات ام تذهب الى
المرتفعات الاستراتيجيه والغابات الى الش
الغربي
لقاء السيطره المحدوده على طرق المواصلات
لمن لمنع تطويق لمنع تطويق باك متر ومنع
الحركه والتقدم باتجاه اسلافيونسك سوليدر
همم كراماتوريست شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء
فايز دويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
حدثنا محمد